[Music]
the philosopher Timothy Leary had some
wildly utopian ideas about what could be
made possible with the computer
revolution in the internet and the
communications revolution that
transpired thereafter and he used to say
that we can actually use these tools to
upgrade our consciousness right to
electrify our thoughts so that our memes
could travel at the speed of light and
spray eyeballs through the screen and
lead to altered states of consciousness
spaces of ecstatic illumination so that
we can use our technology to upgrade the
mind of mankind and who knows if that
might happen we're moving now towards
what people refer to as a sharing
economy where people can tweet and share
and upload and repurpose and
reconstitute and recombine ideas in ways
that they never could before you know of
course it calls into question things
like copyright things like how to tag
original work what makes something
original when it can be so easily
transformed than we conceived does that
make it something new is everything a
remix of what came before as Kirby
Ferguson says or are we just moving into
a space where people can borrow steal
and repurpose without giving due credit
I mean you know technology's always been
a double-edged sword it extends but it
also amputates as Marshall McLuhan used
to say it also opens up new
possibilities faces for human expression
for human dialogue for human engagement
this communication revolution has always
been about extending our capacity in
both directions and it's up to us to see
how we'll use these new tools to
transform when we are into what we might
be
[Music]